what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today from paul our
friend over at heavy spoilers i think
the moon eye trailer confirms a big
theory and in details and such paul when
your twins are born i believe next month
i'm just so honored that you would name
your twins after greg
and greg you're naming both of them greg
it's an unheard of case and you know
what i think it's for the better because
it's always fun to be like which one's
which oh my gosh and and both in their
name greg that's
that's really sweet to you thank you and
if you don't name them that then there's
gonna be a lot of people very
disappointed so you don't want to
disappoint people you don't want to lose
subscribers you'll lose subscribers if
you if you if you don't name them both
can't think of any other names no
definitely not not a single four-letter
name other than greg
all right johnny right yeah
why don't you just call me greg okay so
the moonlight trailer is something
special and piecing it all together is
like solving a rubik's cube that's
constantly rotating as oscar isaac's
mark specter jumps in and out of his
alternate personalities throughout he
watches timid steven grant starts to
learn about the other facets of his life
and just in case you don't know in the
comics mark is the dominant persona in
the source material he traveled to
ancient egypt and discovered a dig that
unearthed the shrine dedicated to the
god conscious after mark was badly
beaten by the person leading the dig he
pledged his life to the god so that he
could get revenge and he became his
avatar moon knight
one thing when talking with paul about
when we were speculating about what he's
punching there i know that the common
thing has been is that a werewolf is
that anubis paul was speculating that it
actually could be a jackal
a jackal it's a jackal it's a jackal
it's not a jekyll jackal it's a jackal
it looks like a jackal i don't know what
that really does for me and i hope it's
a big deal after all the speculation yes
i was like what the hell that damn
now the show doesn't look like it's
going in this chronological direction
and instead i think that we're gonna get
a similar style to one division where
we're dropping at the deep end and left
trying to piece things together i
actually think the series will open with
us from steven's point of view and then
over the course of the series he'll
figure things out and this will lead
into him discovering everything about
mark which in turn will also fill the
audience in i actually really like the
idea of that structure for the fact that
this is gonna be a darker show which a
lot of people when you say that makes us
think of the netflix series and the
netflix series a lot of times they
wouldn't show their origin tale to like
the third or fourth episode so i wonder
if they'll kind of do a similar thing
here oh it'll be like the centerpiece of
the season now in order to talk about
the next part of the video i want to
give a huge shout out to glorious
purpose on twitter who said that he
thinks that mark was snap and then when
he was brought back this is when he
changed to stephen and he has been him
ever since this would explain why he
gets a phone call from someone who seems
surprised he's alive and it would also
explain another big part of the teaser
now during it we see a chase in which
he's in a truck being chased by what i
assume are arthur harrow's men there is
a moment where we see followers of
harrow bang before him and in the corner
you can catch the same truck that mark
later drives there are also soldiers
there with guns so it makes sense that
this is all possible
in this before they go after him at some
point he goes over a cliff and hills to
his death but we cut before we see how
he gets out of this
[Music]
now it is possible that he transforms
into his moonlight costume at this point
but typically he appears at night and i
think it would be weird to have a
vigilante in broad daylight at this
point it also begs to question why he
waited up until this moment to transform
when he could have done it at any point
in the scene before this therefore i
actually think that he'll get snap
whilst falling to the ground and that
this will be what saves his life if you
catch it
you might remember one of the big
questions floating around about it is
what happened to people who were on a
plane that got snapped when they were
brought back if they were put in the
exact same position as where the plane
was when they disappeared they'd fall to
their death but the russos cleared this
all up they said smart hulk accounted
for this and that everyone was brought
back safely on the ground which i think
would also happen with mark this would
allow steven to take over mark but mark
constantly wanting to bust out could
itch away at him and make him suspect
that something else is going on it will
also allow him to get away from harrow
and then perhaps the pair bump into each
other five years later in the museum
which is where he tells them to embrace
the chaos i actually really like that
theory a lot one thing that we've been
seeing with dealing with the snapper
post blip the traumatic experiences of
dealing with having been snapped away
for so long and having to get readjusted
to life and from the trailer alone even
without acknowledging the thanos snap
it's already dealing with the harrowing
nature commenting on disassociative
identity disorder how do i belong when i
don't even know who i am
so using what we've already thematically
been dealing with with the snap if you
apply that to him here it's just that
much more accentuated at that point oh
yeah one as far as like sci-fi
mumbo-jumbo goes i actually really like
that as getting us to you know having
this steven grant character be sort of
at the center through that sort of
experience of yeah like i don't know if
it would add it to his personality array
or not seems like something strange
might happen in the five-year you know
oblivion that you go to strange
easter eggs a little is known about
harrow and even in the comics he's quite
an obscure character that was basically
just a mad scientist during his face-off
against moonlight one of the priests of
konshu appeared to him when he was on
the road and it sent him visions of
harrow carrying out human experiments
harrow had won the nobel prize but there
was a lot of questions about how he
managed to achieve medical development
when it seemed like all he had done was
carry out tests on animals however it
wasn't covered by mark that he'd been
doing these on people but the show
doesn't really seem to be going in that
direction i think that in the series we
will learn that when mark was a merc he
discovered the shrine of konchu in egypt
and then he became his vessel mark then
likely continued doing mercenary ops one
involving spying on harrow he then
witnessed things firsthand and harrow
got his followers to fight him in the
disney plus day trailer we did see a
scene in which he was surrounded by
people he'd knocked out in a street that
looks similar the one that we see harrow
in the character seems a bit confused as
to how this happened almost like he's
snapping out of something so i think
this might be him jumping to stephen
from mark if our theories are right then
the chase likely took place and this led
to him falling out the van which could
have tied into the snap and then he was
brought back five years later as steven
he then could have bumped into harrow at
the museum which seems to be the
location a meeting is happening at due
to the statues in the background
i am interested in seeing what they
could do with harrow and i actually
think they might even combine him with
other characters ethan hawk has
described him as the david karashesque
villain that's the leader of a cult and
in order to get this reputation i wonder
if he has any powers or abilities
himself it has been theorized for a
while that he's playing sun king and i
even got so deep into this that come the
release of the trailer i just assumed it
was him big l for kevin spoilers on that
there's no reason for a big l on that
the subtitles confirmed it though i
think yes on the actual trailer itself
right but the thought that was kind of
popping in my head while watching this
was a little bit of what they've kind of
been doing with venom it would appear in
the trailer that whenever he does
something or shifting between
personalities she has no memory
recollection of the other's personality
when you're thinking about a long-term
series or for a character i'd imagine
they'd have to get to a point where the
personalities can successfully coexist
where he could adopt the other memories
because i like the idea of being
thrusted into situations where he has
deniability because he really doesn't
remember it whatsoever right i like
dealing with the chaos of that but i'm
wondering if eventually there will be an
arc where the personalities will have to
learn to cooperate with each other kind
of like venom and tom harper yeah yeah
and then when moon knight takes over
it's a little bit like oh god now why
come on like work with me here yeah i
could absolutely see that and with the
harrow character too i i gotta imagine
they're going to use that small comic
book character appearance as some kind
of mislead to then usher in a much
bigger character like sun god or
something like that good point now the
internet has been full of people
pointing out amazing easter eggs such as
that and the box in the van that has von
d on it this has led many to believe
that it's actually a no to the major
marvel villain victor von doom however
it was quickly debunked as in the next
shot you can see that the box reads von
darrellman which is the name of a
cupcake company however however however
none of you folks are as clever as i am
i actually think that in the marvel
universe victor von doom will be a
cupcake king who runs a criminal empire
selling delicious baked goods in the
comics dr doom actually got hit in the
face with a cupcake once which was
likely his super villain origins
oh my god it's all starting to make
sense now isn't it exclusive theory
exclusive exclusive exclusive
anyway back to stephen now the character
is clearly
paranoid and in the teaser we can see
that he tapes up the door so that if
it's opened he'd find this torn there's
also even a ring of sand put around his
bed to show if there's been any
footprints this goes on for several
nights and we can actually tell this by
the fact that his clothes change however
another theory could be that it's all
part of the same night and the change of
clouds is because he became someone else
while stephen was asleep one of the most
interesting parts of the new look is him
solving a rubik's cube which i theorized
represented his fractured personalities
all being part of one whole the constant
twist and turning of this could also
represent how he drops in and out of his
different personas huge shout outs to
youtube user ralph shadow for jumping
off that and saying that come the end of
the season there would be a lot of
symbolism to stephen completing it this
would show the balancing of all his
personalities and as rubik's cubes
typically take a long time to solve it
could be something that he keeps going
back to doesn't take me a long time
though as i figured out that doctor doom
cupcake thing oh yeah i think that would
be a great direction to take the series
i think the doctor do things so funny
because you've done something brilliant
here because i saw it going around
social media and i was like i don't
think they're they're not dr doom would
be on some box in this background this
is how we introduce one of our most
iconic villains but flip it on its head
here we're just finding a part of the
comics that dealt with cupcakes and
doctor do now i'm at the point where i'm
like i'm hoping that's true now just
because of paul in the finale episode of
the season someone's gonna hurl one of
those cupcakes and that big metal hand's
gonna grab it out of thin air uh i can't
believe your name your twins correct
that's
though many people think that the thing
that was stalking him in the museum was
konchu who does show up in trailer 2. i
actually think that this is the beast in
the bathroom if you look at it it has
glowing eyes whereas conscious doesn't
and the god carries a staff whereas this
creature is missing it thus i think it
might have been sent out by anubis to
collect whatever stephen has in the bag
and he eventually ends up defeating it
in a bathroom however he did hunt
werewolves in the comics and the
character first appeared in werewolf by
night but the lack of fur and shape of
the animal makes me think it's the other
anyway
i believe we're having not too bad of a
week as we actually get attention
boba fett episode gonna hold on to that
for the rest of time but i'm sure you
have better ones than i've dropped in
this video so make sure you leave yours
in the comments section below great work
there paul really proud of you buddy
yeah i think you're a thanos snap thing
that one lines up pretty well good
detective work my man i always like
seeing when you get predictions and
theories right always always like that
about you kevin spoiler spoilers over
here guys subscribe to heavy spoilers if
you haven't done so already let's get
this guy to a million before the end of
2022 you can subscribe to us click that
notification bell and hey we'll catch
you all soon
you